denim what do we know of this man's
whereabouts
not very much but one of the telegram
channels here called basa say that
they've just had a conversation with his
daughter and she says that he hasn't
been detained and everybody is just
doing their jobs
um but there has been a lot of
speculation over the past few days about
his whereabouts because Sergey sorovicin
is known to have been relatively close
with Evgeni pregosian he was never one
of Russia's top military leadership who
pregocian would criticize in his many
vocal angry terrains in fact pregosian
once said that sorovicin would make a
good chief of the general staff and
another man who was a deputy defense
minister Mikhail Miss himself should be
defense minister himself and mizinsef
was uh sacked from the mod in April and
promptly went over and joined Wagner
himself so um there were a lot of
questions about sort of vegan whether he
was too close to Wagner you'll remember
that last year he was appointed head of
operations in Ukraine basically the man
to run the things and he was essentially
the full full guy for Russia's
withdrawal from her son in November
um and then at the beginning of this
year he was once again demoted and
Valerie garasimov was put back in charge
of operations in Ukraine and the
suggestion was that was because
surovicin was too close to Wagner and
Putin and Choi had decided it was time
to try and get Wagner in line and uh
bring them more under the remit of the
control of the mod and the mod all
together and the final iteration of that
was this contract spat which seems to
have been the final trigger for
pregosian to wage his his march on
Moscow
um so the the video of solovicin from
Friday night as you say uh was urging
pregojin to desist from
um staging a mutiny but there have been
a lot of questions over whether that was
forced I suppose what I would say is
that he doesn't he's not a public figure
he doesn't you know look very good on
camera it's not his natural
place to be and the same applies for the
fact that we haven't seen him in public
we haven't seen Valerie grasimov either
but I remember other times when we've
talked about the fact that we haven't
seen garasimov he's just not a public
figure they don't wheel him out
um for this kind of occasion but the um
Ministry of Defense won't comment the
Kremlin say it's up to the ministry of
Defense so that's where we are but it
would be interesting
um to know because of all of these
questions there's also a suggestion that
um this reporting is coming out as a
sort of information operation to try and
destabilize Russia's military leadership
and that the generals are just getting
on with their job well we don't know but
there is a lot of rumors of a possible
Purge amongst the security forces as a
result of
um precautions March and that's why
these questions are so live
and also the person we have seen also is
President Putin we've seen a lot of them
over the last few days what did you make
of his latest appearance
well today he's giving a rather mundane
speech um at a at an event for a
creative thinking uh yesterday the
pictures were extraordinary he was down
in Dagestan in the city of dead bent
there uh he doesn't make many trips down
to Dagestan
um and he doesn't make many trips where
he goes into the throng of crowds and
starts shaking hands you know there we
saw lots of people holding up their
mobile phones trying to touch the
president does seem to be a kind of new
touchy-feely President Putin very
different from uh the man who you would
have to do three separate covid tests
before you were allowed in the same room
as him
um so I'm sure the Kremlin is trying to
Workshop His Image as a more amenable
figure for the general public
um in the wake of this especially after
those comments that he made that the
Army and the people were were with the
state
um and that what prigon was doing was
treason we've definitely seen from
Vladimir Putin a real effort to put
emphasis on the fact that the Army and
the people stand behind him and now here
he is lots of pictures of him going and
being one with the people we'll probably
see a bit more of that in the coming
days too